Speaker 1: All right, I'm going to play for
you just a little bit. A little bit of another
one of these bogus interviews with employees from
Facebook. We've now had one or two of these every
single day. The back story, of course, is that we
had these whistleblower documents leaked. We now
actually learned the identity, Frances Hogan of
the whistleblower on 60 Minutes Sunday testified
on Monday or Tuesday of this week. And Facebook
has been falling all over itself to respond
to the different claims, including sort of most
importantly, we could say that they know Facebook
and or Instagram are so good for a lot of people's
mental health, and that a lot of the things that
do most well on the platforms are disinformation
and things that are bad for body image and so on
and so forth. And they still allow the algorithm
at minimum, if not, encourage the algorithm to
surface those things because it generates clicks
and it generates engagement, keeps people on on
the platform and generates ad revenue as a result.
So we had an interview on NPR earlier in the week
with one guy who seemed completely unprepared. We
had an interview from CNN on yesterday's show with
a woman who was sort of like denying every claim
that was being made, even though they were really
non-denial denials. They were very squishy
denials. Now I have video here of Facebook's
global head of security, Antigeni Davis. That name
brings me back to a junior English antigeni Davis,
who, without really denying that pushing
content that upsets people is what they do,
says it's it wouldn't be logical
for Facebook to do it. Listen
very carefully to what she says. It's actually
Speaker 2: extraordinarily shortsighted. So if
you think about somebody who's experience on
the platform, if they're having a very negative
experience, at some point they're going to turn
away from that from that negative experience. So
to suggest we optimize towards something negative
for the long term value of business just doesn't.
Actually, it is illogical. It doesn't make
Speaker 1: sense. So she's claiming it
wouldn't make sense to optimize for a type of
content that upsets people wouldn't make sense
because then people get upset and then they
leave the platform. Except it doesn't happen.
It doesn't happen partially because people
are sort of addicted to these platforms,
and you can endlessly scroll and see what's
the next thing. Do I have notifications that
someone send me a message? Partially
because there's a sort of like a
slot machine effect where you might scroll and see
something cool or not? And so the variable reward
system works to keep people scrolling. And a lot
of people might feel like crap but not realize
it's because of browsing social media, comparing
yourself to others and whatever else the case may
be. So she, first of all, doesn't really deny she
is, as it would be illogical. It ignores the fact
that this is a business model. I mean, like, think
about tobacco. The long term tobacco cigarets are
not optimized for the long term. Why? Because
they kill the users. OK. But in the short term,
particularly because nicotine is addictive. You
generate a ton of money. So the idea that it's not
it's not a logical business model to do something
that in the long term hurts your customers.
Idiotic, absolutely idiotic. And the denial is
a very, very soft and soft and squishy denial,
as I like to call it now in the midst of all this.
Remember, Facebook also had an outage on Monday.
Facebook has now told the story of why they say
the outage took place. The outage was the longest
stretch of downtime for Facebook since 2008. To
all the people and businesses around the world
who depend on us, we're sorry, said Facebook.
Facebook shares were down five percent Monday,
up one percent Tuesday. Facebook is saying that
the issue was caused by configuration changes
on the backbone routers and what the changes were
was not said. The changes caused quote issues that
interrupted the flow of traffic between routers
in Facebook's data centers around the world.
This disruption to network traffic had a cascading
effect on the way our data centers communicate,
bringing our services to a halt. So for
all of those speculating that this was a
deliberate outage in order to try to smother the
revelations about the Facebook whistleblower.
I understand why you think that
the more I've thought about it,
the less likely I think it is the amount of
reputational damage that Facebook suffered,
as well as significant number of hours during
their at during which their ads weren't running.
There was a financial problem as well. You
could say it was all worth it to smother
the whistleblower stuff, but everybody's
posting the whistleblower stuff now anyway,
so I am leaning against it having been a
deliberate outage. But if you disagree with me,
let me know and we'll have more clips from
these very strange interviews with seemingly
unprepared Facebook executives on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.